hey Kate how's it going it's going
fantastic wait nobody gets the
prescriptions filled on Black Friday so
I got all the time I want the work on my
screenplay oh it's about a pharmacist
obviously who invents a pill that allows
you to use all of your brain oh oh like
limitless like limitless bliss it's
inspired by limitless okay a quick
question um I'm trying to stay relaxed
today so Jerusha gave me these pills
that she caught after her train accident
I just want to make sure I won't get
hooked
alprazolam ah good good times yeah it's
a low dose she'll be okay oh okay have
you anything to drink today just three
mugs of juice and they could be fine
okay no I lied it was seven mugs I just
didn't want you to judge me that's too
much juice cleanse okay well we're uh
only five minutes in and already the
beer tower display got knocked over on
two miles so he's gone and aisle 12 is
covered with blood and class but so good
so good boo I'm keepin it 100 that's not
what that means no I'm when I'm feeling
a little bit sick no Amy do not fall
apart on me okay you just need to stay
calm I need to go what
oh I'm looking for a little girl she has
a big bow in her hair she's carrying a
baby a fashion girl okay relax we're
gonna find here the important thing to
do though is stay calm and see there she
is doing fine
it's all good thank God we got a baby
fashion girl
[Music]
okay guys I know we're bare-bones but we
can still make this work if Sandra could
triple cover camping menswear and soft
lines and er you can do that right I
guess if my knees were normal but three
different doctors say oh so we're all
back here huh we're just taking a little
break we'll get out there in a sec it's
fine
oh you're not feeling sick oh no I feel
terrible worst I've ever felt hey Rob I
care who's watching the floor
[Applause]
form an orderly line hey one TV per
family listen lady I'm putting your face
in my memory palace eyes too far apart
stringy hair ethnic nose oh it's over
and then we just need Herman to cover
everything
Herman hasn't worked here in six months
fine then you know what I don't know how
to make this work it makes you feel any
better this is probably all your fault
that's nothing you made it taste like
burnt hair my stuffing is not what made
us sick if anything there's probably
Dina's weird tofu Turkey thing you know
what's weird eating the flesh off of a
bird's bones you Savage why are you so
weird
is everyone being so mean to each other
guys guys this is what Black Friday
watch that's a family recipe we have a
secret ingredients but this is not what
Black Friday is gonna get Oh cinnamon
boys and we are gonna overcome this
because there's absolute could you
please shut up and that goes for all you
I can't listen to your for one more damn
second did something just happen I think
I dragged out there thank you so much
for shopping at cloud 9
you